die big soldaten aus zwölf nationen
haben auch 2009 10 wieder an der
weltmeisterschaft weggekippt soldaten
der sogenannten edelweiß raid in tirol
teilgenommen
die soldaten zeigen dabei ihr können
wenn es darum geht von lawinen
verschüttete personen zu finden und zu
bergen militärische aufklärung im
hochalpinen gelände durchzuführen
absagen gebirge sowie das errichten
eines biwaks auf über 2000 meter seehöhe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vergessen auch die gbk effizienz lover
chris brown 19 und jetzt zum schluss zu
leihen zum großen stil warum hätte die
vogelsanger das war sehr eng aber es war
nicht perfekt ich bin überglücklich mit
15 kilo gepäck dem sturmgewehr ski und
diverser lawinenausrüstung haben die
teilnehmenden soldatinnen und soldaten
in zwei tagen insgesamt 40 kilometer
wegstrecke zurückgelegt und und 4000
höhenmeter im hochgebirge bewältigt
dieser wettkampf zeigt den extrem hohen
ausbildungsstand nicht nur der
österreicher sondern auch der anderen
teams und ich kann nur eins sagen ich
bin stolz auf unsere mannschaften bin
aber auch stolz auf jeden der hier
teilgenommen hat und das war wirklich
beeindruckend